MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon everyone.
Welcome to another outstanding
Talks at Google event.
And today for our
Food Google program,
we're very thrilled
to welcome back
Jody Eddy and Gunnar
Karl Gislason.
They will be
speaking to us today
about their latest
cookbook, which
is called "North: The New
Nordic Cuisine of Iceland".
And some of us in the audience,
I know myself personally,
have traveled in the
beautiful country,
seen the food that was there,
the fish and everything.
And really with
what the book does
is not only talk about Gunnar's
restaurant-- which is Dill,
and very well known, one of
the top Nordic restaurants
in Iceland and a continuation
of the new Nordic cuisine
tradition from Rene Redzepi.
But the book also
goes into background
about the various producers
throughout the country.
So from the folks that provide
the salt, to the goat's milk,
to the people that
are harvesting bird
eggs off the coast
of Iceland, there's
a story for each one involved.
And so we will have some
time for Q&A at the end,
so I encourage you to
check the book out.
We are sampling some
Icelandic cuisine as well.
Hop on down to the beautiful
country if you get a chance
and please join me in welcoming
Gunnar and Jody to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
JODY EDDY: So thank you
so much for coming today.
And I thought it
would just start out
by talking a little
bit about my history
with Gunnar where we met and I
met him maybe five years ago.
It was right when the economic
collapse of Iceland's economy
had just happened
and I was shooting--
I was an editor at
a culinary magazine
and I was most excited
to meet with Gunnar
of all the chefs
I met in Iceland.
And when I got there,
to the restaurant,
they said that he wasn't there.
And I was really disappointed,
I had to leave the next day.
But then he walked into Dill
carrying a basket of angelica
that he had just been
collecting outside,
and so he had been there.
And we just stayed in
touch throughout the years,
and then a variety of
projects together and.
He was in my last book on
restaurant staff meals.
And when we finished
that up, I didn't really
have a project in
the works with him.
And we had a conversation
that night at the photo shoot
and talked about how we
should do something together,
profiling the traditional
food producers of Iceland
because they're so
important to Gunnar.
Can you talk a little bit about
why they mean so much to you?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Well the thing
is when I first opened
up the restaurant,
it was five and half years ago.
It started up us
being-- like, it
was supposed be, like
a Nordic restaurant.
And I wanted to try
to collect ingredients
from all around the
Nordic countries.
The collapse came and
pretty much everything
that I was going to import was
going up in prices like crazy.
So we somehow started
going another way.
We started with
the usual suspects
and then went from there
trying to find something more,
trying to find something
new-- in my case,
maybe trying to find
something old, actually.
And very quickly I
found this passion
for finding those
producers that are
making their things the old way.
And so I was trying
to find them.
And even harder
was to find out how
I could take those ingredients
and make something,
like new out of it, something
new that would be like-- that
would fit perfectly into
a fine dining restaurant.
And for some things
it was really easy
and came very natural.
For other things, it was
like months of headache.
But--
JODY EDDY: Why was that?
Why was it a challenge?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: I mean
to take a little dried wolffish
and make something really
enjoyable out of it.
Not that I'm saying
it's bad like it is,
but it's more like you will
have to do something with it
so it fits the restaurant.
Usually we just eat it.
Like at home, we just tear it
down, cover it with butter,
and eat it like that.
But obviously I had to do
something a little bit more
interesting so I could
serve it at the restaurant.
And especially, the
dried fish actually
was kind of a headache.
But now I have a
couple of things
that I like doing with it.
JODY EDDY: Hardfiskur,
what he's referencing,
is that a dried wolffish.
It's dried in drying
houses on the ocean.
And it's certainly
a tradition that
is disappearing
in Iceland, and I
think that's what inspires
me most about Gunnar,
is that he is taking these
traditional ingredients
that even maybe Icelanders
aren't appreciating anymore
and he's transforming
them into something
beautiful and contemporary, but
still pays homage to the past.
And his connections
to his producers,
I've so often seen
that he's really
keeping the traditional
alive in some cases,
and in some cases
actually transforming
a tradition, and also
just making Icelanders
appreciate what they have.
GUNNAR KARL
GISLASON: Yes, right.
It's like when I started
researching those things
and finding all those
people at the same time,
I was finding out that
they were really, really
slowly fading away.
And all the companies,
they were coming up
with both easier and cheaper--
and most of all, faster-- ways
to do their things.
Like for example
with the dried fish,
it's mostly dried now
in some kind of ovens.
Which is fine, there's
nothing wrong with it per se.
But it's just not the
same as other one.
The other one obviously
is like really
packed of flavors from the
sea after hanging there.
So the thing is that you have to
find the place for your house,
and you should find
the place where
it's as windy as it
can be, pretty much.
And then it's only dried
during the wintertime
because the temperature
has to be below zero.
And it takes one month,
up to two months,
depending on everything.
And obviously the fish will
be really packed with flavors.
And there are many other
assembles-- for an example,
with a salted cod-- that
is like, back in the days,
it takes almost like up
to a year to make it.
But nowadays it's more
starting to be new ways,
injecting saltwater and
et cetera, et cetera.
But still we are
so lucky to have
a couple that are still
doing it the old way.
And obviously we buy theirs.
JODY EDDY: Absolutely.
And can you talk a little bit--
because I think there's maybe
a bit of misconception about
what New Nordic cuisine is all
about and what Nordic cuisine--
contemporary Nordic cuisine--
is about?
And maybe talk a
little bit about what
the manifesto for the new
Nordic kitchen was and--?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah,
well it's like-- I don't know.
It's actually quite
a long time ago
since the manifesto was made.
It was actually a couple of
chefs from the Nordic countries
that actually all got together
and made this little manifesto
of things that
should be something
that would embrace
our countries.
The whole idea--
the first idea, I
guess-- was to try to
make a kitchen that
could be well-known,
like worldwide.
And I guess people like, they
saw that it could be a problem
to make like one country to
make a Norwegian kitchen,
or a Danish kitchen
for that matter,
and make it like really, really
big so it could get like longer
and wider like the Italian
kitchen or the French kitchen,
et cetera.
So they decided
somehow-- and I think
that was one of the reasons that
it would be good to take them
all together,
somehow like trying
to take the Nordic countries
and everybody like work together
and try to embrace
each other and that we
could get that Nordic
kitchen on the map.
And it happened
so fast and so big
that I think nobody believed it.
And now it's, I don't know, it's
like somehow maybe those words,
like the Nordic
kitchen, are-- for me,
at least-- some people
use it to describe
a certain type of food.
But for me, it's more
like a Nordic kitchen
would be like a
restaurant that are using
those ingredients that
are close to them.
But they could be
really different
when it comes to
how to make the food
or how to plate it or
serve it for that matter.
So for me it's like
a very big umbrella
for a lot of things for a lot
of kitchens, techniques, and et
cetera.
JODY EDDY: And I think
one of the things
that we really talk a
lot about in our cookbook
is that you can take
these techniques,
or you can take this
philosophy and really apply it
anywhere in the world,
and incorporate it.
They talk so much about a sense
of place in Nordic countries
and associated with
the term New Nordic.
And it really does mean that,
you know-- look outside.
If there's something in the
cookbook that you can't source,
just find out what's in your
own backyard and use that.
And I think that's really
the philosophy of what
Nordic cuisine is about, as
opposed to specific techniques
or ingredients.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: You
just go into your backyard
and find whatever
you have and use it.
JODY EDDY: Yeah.
Can you talk a little
bit more about--?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Just make sure not
to eat something poison.
[LAUGHTER]
JODY EDDY: Exactly.
Can you talk a little bit
more about the techniques--
like the specific
techniques-- in Iceland
that are really
unique to Iceland?
Cooking techniques,
maybe your hay smoking
and smoking with
manure and those.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Yeah, probably now you
want to hear about the manure.
[LAUGHTER]
It's actually like-- that's
one of the old traditions
as well, probably since
the time of Vikings.
It's something that was
a technique that-- so,
during the winter
time, the sheeps
would be inside the houses.
They would all,
obviously, they would
do number one and
two on the floor
and have some hay in between.
And they'd walk on
it the whole winter.
So it's thick like this in
the beginning of the summer.
In the beginning of
the summer, the sheeps,
they just go up to the
mountains and live really
freely there all summer.
The farmers on the
other hand, they
would go and cut it into layers,
take it outside, and dry it.
And it's actually
it's like-- I thought
it was like a really
basic technique,
but it's really kind
of complicated to find
the exact right manure to use.
Because it cannot be too
dry, it cannot be too wet.
If it's too dry, it will
just go up in flames.
If it's too wet, it
obviously won't burn.
So it's a kind of
complicated technique.
And obviously it
takes a long time,
and obviously you
have to have sheeps.
But it's probably like
something that-- I mean,
they didn't start doing
it because they really
just love their shit so much.
But it's probably
more because they
didn't have anything
else to burn.
So there were a serious, serious
lack of trees in Iceland.
And it actually went so
far that at a certain time
they started to try to protect
those few trees that we
had left.
So obviously people have
to find something else
to dry and burn or
smoke with, or whatever.
So this was one of the things
that they came up with.
JODY EDDY: And I think
that's certainly something,
after traveling in
Iceland for many years,
that I see over and over again
is that they-- often, it's
a matter of survival, really.
And so you really have to
be clever and figure out
how to use what you have.
We'll talk a little bit later
about the geothermal salt
maker who makes salt using
geothermal heat, the rye bread
producer who uses, instead of
wood, using geothermal heat
from the ground in baking
the bread in the ground.
There's just so many different
ingredients and techniques
that I think really reflect
that tradition of not having
anything and just
having to be clever.
Yeah, and can you just
talk a little bit more
about the geothermal
energy and the heat,
and also about how Iceland
is such a pristine country?
They've tried to market
Iceland as one of the only 100%
sustainable nations
because of the fact
that you don't have chemicals,
the animals are free range,
they don't use antibiotics.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Most of it, at least.
We try to use that heat from
the ground for some good things,
definitely.
But obviously it can sometimes
be a little bit hard,
because, I think,
I can't use it,
because I would have to drive
pretty far away to find one.
But on those areas where they
have that geothermal heat,
it is used quite a lot.
I think we can use it even more.
But for an example, we
have that salt producer.
And they're-- it's
somehow it's like I really
don't-- it's really only
like a couple of years old,
that company.
And now there are two
companies making high-end salt
in Iceland.
But for me it's
just really strange
that we haven't been
doing this like always,
because it's so simple.
The only thing they do is
they pump some seawater up
from the sea and
up in some tanks,
and they dry it over
geothermal heat.
JODY EDDY: That's it.
And it's the best
finishing salt and salt
that I've truly ever eaten.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
It's really good.
But the same with the heat,
obviously like on those places
where there is a lot
of heat in the ground,
people will use it to cook
with, like to bake the bread,
for example.
And obviously we use
it for our greenhouses.
So it's like-- I mean,
greenhouses in general
may be quite often
looked down at.
But I think it
could be something
that we could be proud of in
Iceland because of that heat
from the ground
that has been used,
and how green our
electricity is.
JODY EDDY: And also--
here's a picture.
What you're seeing
there is whale.
And I thought we could talk
a little bit about some
of the products that they use in
Iceland, because so often it's
all they have, and I think
it can be very controversial.
But I also think it speaks
to using what's around you.
And if you can talk a little
bit more about things maybe
they would call taboo,
horse meat and whale and--?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Yeah, I mean,
it's like-- definitely,
back in the days, people,
they had to survive.
And they were not going to have
some big issues about if it
was a whale or something else.
If they could cook
it and eat it,
they would probably just do it.
Now, it's like whale--
there's not really
many people in Iceland who are
eating it, not many at all.
I'm actually pretty sure it's
like most of the whale sold
in Iceland is sold to tourists.
But there are some more
things like, for an example,
horses, which are
eaten all year round.
And I actually had
issues eating horse,
but it is because I came
from the countryside,
and we raised horses.
So it was a little bit
like eating my dog.
But then again, people
do that as well.
JODY EDDY: Not in Iceland.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Not in Iceland, no.
But then I decided a couple
of months ago, I was like, OK.
Let's go.
So obviously, I had eaten
some horses back in day.
But it's actually really good.
If you find the right producer
and you find the right horse,
actually it's
really, really nice.
JODY EDDY: I think one
of the questions I always
get when people hear
that I'm working
on an Icelandic cookbook
is, what is the shark like?
And again, I think it's one
of those tired questions
that, there are some notorious
ingredients in Iceland that
are very traditional and really,
again, speak to that time
when food was about survival.
It was about getting
through the winter
and using preservation
techniques.
They don't necessarily
appeal to the modern palate,
but I think it's important
that these traditions continue,
because it's really
the legacy of Iceland
and the legacy of
surviving and perseverance.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Yeah, exactly.
And I mean it's like a good
question about that shark,
because it's something-- I
mean, I wouldn't go so far
to say that I really dislike
it, but it's not really pleasant
at all.
It smells like
really, really strong.
But actually after you
start you eating it,
it smells more than
it actually tastes.
And a lot of people
actually, it's
like-- I met a lot
of foodies people
that are really
into strong cheeses.
And they actually just
happen to enjoy this a lot,
because it's like the texture
and everything is actually
a lot like a strong cheese.
And it's like again, even though
I don't really love eating it,
it would be a big shame
if it were to die out.
And the technique, again, is
something that takes months.
Yeah, it would be a shame.
JODY EDDY: Yeah.
And we did meet with
a-- so it's a fermented
or, essentially,
putrefied Shark.
And we met with a--
it's called hakarl--
with a hakarl producer.
And talking with him-- he's
in his, I think, 80s now--
and there isn't
anyone who is going
to take over what he's doing.
And so even if this
ingredient isn't something
that appeals to
everyone, it's really sad
that it might disappear
when he disappears.
I have a picture
here of puffins.
And that's another ingredient
I think in Iceland that it's
a part of Icelandic tradition,
but not necessarily something
that you would--
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: It's very
like-- what do you call it?
It's very like, a local thing.
So he's not just everywhere.
But, yeah definitely like
[INAUDIBLE] and Grimsey,
they will have a lot of it,
[INAUDIBLE] and in the west.
But now it's
protected, in a way.
I think you're allowed
to go and hunt it,
but you're not
allowed to sell it
and you're not allowed to
sell it in the restaurants.
Yeah, but it's a very
big tradition in Iceland
to eat those.
And not only those, but to a lot
of birds in their same family,
and even at a time of
some of their eggs.
JODY EDDY: And here's a photo
of somebody baking-- I'm sorry,
cooking, eggs in
geothermal water.
And again, that's an old
tradition that is not common
anymore, but it is
something from the past
that I think is really
fascinating and very uniquely
Iceland.
And so I just thought we could
talk a little bit about what
Viking stock is, if
you can address that,
and talk about why
Iceland's animals are
truly unique in the world?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
So it's like Iceland
has those rules somehow like
to protect their species.
So it's illegal
to, for an example,
if you were going to take this
horse to a show in Denmark,
you're not allowed
to take it back.
And you're not allowed to
import other types of horses.
And this goes for, more
or less, every animal.
JODY EDDY: And
these were animals
that were introduced by the
Vikings in the 9th century.
So they are unique species
on the planet because they
have never bred
with other species.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Exactly.
And it's is like-- maybe you
can speak about your goats?
JODY EDDY: We met a
goat farmer in Iceland
who had been a
nurse in Reykjavik.
And she quit her job
maybe eight years ago
because the Icelandic
goat population
had dipped to below 90 animals.
And she realized that if
she didn't do something,
they might go extinct.
And so the goat
population now hovers
around 900 animals in Iceland.
And, truly, thanks to
Johanna Thorvaldsdottir,
I think, because
of her work, people
are starting to appreciate
the goats again and really see
that it's important
to not only protect
the goats for the sake of
the goats but it's a legacy
and it's history that
they're protecting.
But Johanna runs the
only commercial goat
farm in Iceland.
And she has about 400 of
the goats on her farm.
And her farm was about to go
into foreclosure-- actually,
next week.
And so they were going to
slaughter her goats, which
would mean it would wipe
out half the population.
And so we started an
Indiegogo campaign for her,
just me and a friend.
And we've raised over
$110,000 in about a month.
And her farm will be safe now,
and her goats will be saved.
But I think the
important thing about it
is that it really
speaks to the fact
that the Icelandic
people are starting
to appreciate what they have.
And she has said to me,
since this campaign started,
her tours on the farm have
increased exponentially
because now there
is an appreciation.
And I think it speaks to what
you're all about as well,
that you have often used
ingredients that weren't
necessarily-- they weren't
used by Icelandic people,
such as blue mussels.
They have the most beautiful,
pristine blue muscles
in Iceland, but they
weren't using them.
And then when they
show up on your table,
they start to show up on
other restaurant tables.
And then maybe they're
bought by the consumer,
and it's just interesting
to watch it trickle out.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Definately, definitely.
And I mean like a lot of other
things, like for seaweed,
for an example.
JODY EDDY: This
is actually-- he's
the seaweed and blue
mussel harvester
that Gunnar works with.
Can you talk a little bit
more about him and his work?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Yeah, so his name is Simon.
He lives in the west.
He lives on the Snaefellsnes.
So he has a small company.
I think there are like three
or something working there.
And so he grows blue
mussels and then
he collects a couple
types of seaweed
and sells to the
local restaurants.
And he is even exporting
some of his seaweed as well.
So he's doing great.
JODY EDDY: Absolutely, so we'll
get to some of our producers
here.
So these are some of the herbs
that they use in Iceland.
And what are some of
those common herbs
that you'd find in
your kitchen at Dill?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Well, I
use probably most of angelica.
Angelica, maybe chervil,
those are probably
the most common ones
that I use a lot.
Arctic thyme obviously,
really, really delicious,
especially when it's in bloom.
But it's like, then
we take the trees,
we go for birch trees,
pine trees and et cetera.
And probably like the best
part about foraging in Iceland
is there are pretty much
nothing in the nature
that will actually kill
you if you taste it.
So you can actually go,
you can just go there.
You just go and taste
everything and you don't really
have to worry about it.
So that's pretty good.
JODY EDDY: It's very fun.
So Gunnar and I-- these are just
a few shots of Iceland itself.
And we traveled, we probably
ringed the country--
two or three times?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Yeah, probably.
JODY EDDY: We hit every
corner of Iceland.
And it is very fun
to travel with him,
because you do eat
everything and you
learn so much about
what's around you.
And I found myself, when I
travel in other countries,
thinking about now
what I could try
that I'm seeing on the ground.
And so these are just a few
shots of us on our road trip,
Gunnar relaxing.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
There is no place better
to relax than Icelandic moss.
JODY EDDY: It's really, I
think, maybe challenging.
Our photographer, his
name is Evan Sung,
he's talked about how it's
challenging in Iceland
because everything is beautiful
and every corner that you turn,
it feels more beautiful
than the last.
And it's a good problem to have,
but it can be overwhelming.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
A thing as well
is like one of the first
ideas about this book
was because I really
wanted to have it
in almost three chapters.
I wanted to try to talk a
lot about our producers,
and especially
those that are doing
their traditional stuff and
maybe kind of fading out.
And I really wanted to have
a whole lot of landscape,
because that somehow
it's like-- that's
what inspires me, mostly.
And then of course,
like the food.
So it's-- yeah.
JODY EDDY: This is bacalao,
which is salted cod.
And can you talk a
little bit about Elvar,
our bacalao producer
in the book.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
So I've been buying
bacalao from Elvar
for a lot of years,
many years actually.
He lives in a really,
really small village
in the North part of
Iceland called Hauganes.
I think it's like 70 people
or something that lives there.
And I think it's
like-- I think he said,
I asked how many people
there from the village
actually worked for him.
I think he said all, except
two old ladies or something.
JODY EDDY: He sustains
his entire village
with his bacalao factory.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
He's a fantastic guy.
So he's like third generation
of salted cod maker.
So what he has
there is obviously
very important and dear to him.
So he uses like
this old technique,
so it takes up to a year
to make it, to salt it.
And then they put it in
water actually, after.
And he makes two kinds.
He makes this one,
and then he makes
one that is dried out
in the sun as well.
And you can only imagine how
often that is in Iceland.
It's like it rains
constantly, so it's--
JODY EDDY: It's a challenge.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah,
you have to jump out dry,
and-- so it's a challenge.
But as well, it's a lot
of fun to go and visit
him and talk to him.
And get all his feelings
that he has for his company.
And it makes it so much more
fun to actually use the product.
And even to hear him say
like we've been asking him
if he's pressing
his kids because--
JODY EDDY: To take over.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Yeah, to take over,
because they have
to be the fourth.
JODY EDDY: He was
telling me that he
might skip his daughters but
that his grandchildren are
very interested.
But I think Elvar
really speaks to me
about-- if his work disappears,
he is maybe the last,
if not one of the last
bacalao producers in Iceland.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: I think
there are probably three.
JODY EDDY: Yeah.
And so he's a very
jovial person, one
of the funniest people I've
ever met in Iceland or anywhere.
But his work is important.
It's really critical.
There was always that question
in the book to each producer,
will somebody take over
this work do you think?
With him there's optimism
there because his grandkids
do seem interested.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
Definitely.
JODY EDDY: But it's been
interesting, as well,
to meet with these producers
throughout the years
because, you know, with
Elvar, he was really
struggling after that
economic collapse.
And I visited him.
I do some Iceland
culinary tours,
and I visited him
maybe last month.
And he's doing better.
He's selling to companies
throughout Europe.
So it's been really great
to watch their evolution
and to see that they're
surviving and thriving
in some cases.
So this is the Arctic char
that you actually tried today.
Can you talk a little bit
about him and his work?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
Those are the ones
that are smoking
the old traditional way, the
one with the lamb manure.
So his name is Gisli, and
he's married to my niece.
JODY EDDY: Cousin.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Cousin.
And they live in
[INAUDIBLE] which
is in the north part of
Iceland, actually not
so far away from
where I actually come.
I pretty much told you
all about that technique
about that smoking.
But it's actually a good story
as well because he actually
smokes his fish like this so
it still has a lot of skin
and a lot of bones on it.
He will then, after
smoking, he will cut off
the bones and all that stuff.
And he actually
puts it in barrels
and keeps the barrels outside
pretty much fermenting
until the winter.
And then he actually
gets the sheeps
into the houses and he
actually feeds it to the--
JODY EDDY: The bones.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
--to the sheeps.
So it's like this
really nice circle
because then they do
their thing on the floor
and he uses it to smoke it.
JODY EDDY: And these are
the geothermal bread ovens
that you tasted the
geothermal bread today.
And talk a little bit about
that and that tradition.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Especially in [INAUDIBLE]
it's a big, big tradition.
And each family usually
has their own hole.
So it's like they just--
JODY EDDY: That they inherit
through the generations.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Exactly.
So they just continue using it.
And it's actually
quite interesting,
you would think that they
would have to dig quite deep,
but it's not deep at all.
It's just like this
and the heat is there.
JODY EDDY: They put their batter
in a bucket or sometimes a milk
container and they leave it
for 24 hours and it cooks.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Exactly.
Yeah.
And usually it's baked in
those used milk containers
for some reason.
JODY EDDY: And there it is.
They sometimes call
it geyser bread.
And then this is a lamb
farmer that we met.
And tell her story
and his story.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: I
actually used to work on a farm
back in the days for his
grandmother and grandfather.
So actually after his father and
mother stopped being farmers,
he took over their farm.
And that farm is
called Mother Daughter,
and there's no farm in Iceland
that is on a higher level
than their farm is.
And it's actually
really impressive
to come there and meet
them and especially
see their sheeps actually,
because it's so high up
and there's so little grass.
So those sheeps, really
have to-- well, there's
obviously a lot of grass
there-- but it's very, sandy.
JODY EDDY: That's
a turf house, so--
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
It's very sandy.
So the sheeps, they
really have to work
hard to find the right spots
and they do a lot of climbing.
And they are massive.
They are really,
really in good shape.
JODY EDDY: And this is a
barley farmer in the east.
He has a farm called Vallanes.
Just quickly, Iceland
had prohibition on beer
until, I think, the 1990s.
And so they lost
their barley tradition
because they weren't using
it for beer any longer.
And he is really an
incredible person.
I feel he maybe
single-handedly returned
the tradition of using barley
to the Icelandic people.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
I think he's like one of very
few that actually grows barley.
And it seems to go
very well for him.
He as well makes a whole lot
of fantastic vegetables--
JODY EDDY: That's
his barley fields.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
--that are organic and nice.
Yeah.
This is his barley.
JODY EDDY: And he started
this farm in an area
where there were no trees.
And he said the
elevation is pretty high.
And he said there was criticism
of him in the beginning
because they said there's
not enough oxygen there
to grow your barley.
And he said, you know what?
I'm going to create
my own oxygen.
And he started his
farm 25 years ago
and he's planted over a million
birch trees on his property.
And he really has
created his own forest
and his own ecosystem.
He's incredibly inspiring.
He has a company now
called Modir Jord
that sells his barley
and other products.
And you see it everywhere
in Iceland now.
And, again, when I started
traveling in Iceland
you couldn't find it anywhere.
And it's encouraging
to see now that there's
an interest in Iceland
for these products.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
Definitely.
When the crisis actually hit us,
which was obviously not really
good, but there came a lot of
good things out of it, though.
There seemed to be like a lot of
people that actually obviously
lost their jobs, and they
would start thinking, OK, now I
have to do something else.
And there was no job to
get, so they pretty much had
to find out something
new, something
that they would like to do,
something that they obviously
knew.
So they opened up like a
whole lot of new companies
doing really, really
interesting things.
JODY EDDY: And I
think as well, we've
talked about how with
the economic crisis,
beforehand everyone was
importing everything.
And so they have this incredible
lamb, an amazing smoked lamb,
but they were importing
prosciutto and eating that
instead.
I mean, I think that's
a really good example.
And after the crisis they could
no longer afford to do that.
And so they started to
appreciate their smoked lamb,
their other products that
were right around them
at their feet.
And it's certainly
a silver lining.
You endured so much.
But--
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
Definitely.
JODY EDDY: Can you talk a little
bit about the dairy in Iceland?
Icelanders consume
more dairy, I think,
than any other
population in the world.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
I'm pretty sure.
JODY EDDY: Talk a
little bit about skyr.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
I think with the
dairies, I mean,
there's not so much to
say about them, I guess.
They are really good.
But the biggest
tradition probably
is an Icelandic milk
product called skyr.
It's somewhere between a
yogurt and a cheese, actually.
And it's actually originally
it's made with live bacterias.
So the farmers would usually
just skim their milk,
so they would take
all the cream away.
And they took the
fat free milk out.
And even the story says that
when they were moving or were
starting a farm somewhere,
they would split it
in a couple of
jars-- take one down
to the river, another
one to the sea,
and one up to the
mountain or something
so they could find
out where they
could find the best starter.
So they would have
some live bacterias
that they would sit down in
the milk and actually make it,
what do you call it?
Curdle, right?
JODY EDDY: Yeah.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
And then they
would get this product skyr,
and the other one called whey.
That's like-- skyr is-- it's
like everybody in Iceland
eats it at least
once a day, I think.
JODY EDDY: Absolutely.
GUNNAR KARL
GISLASON: It's crazy.
JODY EDDY: And it's amazing.
This is a birch forager
and producer that we met.
And if you tasted Gunnar's
schnapps and liqueur,
this is the forest
that it came from.
And the birch twig inside
is from this forest.
I think she's in
the east, as well.
And she also
produces birch syrup,
which, again, I think was
a tradition that you used
to have in Iceland and it
would decrease a little bit.
And she now sells her birch
syrup throughout Iceland.
And it seems to be
something that Icelanders
are appreciating.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Oh, yeah.
Definitely.
And she makes a lot of spice
blends and salts and et cetera,
all just using the
birch three, actually.
JODY EDDY: And there's
one of his sous
chefs with his birch tattoo.
That's how important it is.
This is the salt maker from
Saltverk, the geothermal salt
company that we covered.
And I think that story's
very interesting.
And tell a little bit more
about how that started.
GUNNAR KARL
GISLASON: Definitely.
Well it started
actually in Denmark.
So there were like
two friends that
went to Denmark to
study to be engineers.
For some reason that
I can't remember,
they started reading some
books, like old books.
And then they found out that
the Danish king actually
had people making salt
in Iceland for him
back in the days.
So they started to
take a look into that
and actually ended up opening
up their own salt company.
JODY EDDY: And they're
doing really well.
And that, again,
when we started,
you really couldn't
find their salt anywhere
and now it's everywhere.
Every restaurant table
that I saw last month
seemed to have
Saltverk on the table.
It's encouraging.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
The thing as well
is that it's like for Iceland.
And in Iceland, at
the end of the day,
it's like we're only
like 320,000 people.
So it's like, if
you will come up
with a product that is
actually really good,
it's actually kind of easy
to-- what do you call it?
JODY EDDY: Distribute it?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Get it
to the market, yeah, exactly.
People will talk about it.
JODY EDDY: Yeah.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Like
one restaurant to another
or one house mother to another.
People will talk and
it will go really fast.
But at the same time,
it's like if you come up
with something horrible
it's never going to work.
JODY EDDY: Because everyone's
going to talk about that.
And this is hardfiskur
that you tried today.
So, again, what I
think is inspiring
as well in Iceland
is they really try,
I think, to use
all their products.
So these are drying racks.
They use only the fillets
of the wolffish fish
for the hardfiskur,
but they then
dry the heads and the
bones and they send them
to parts of Africa where
they're used in stews.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
Exactly.
A lot of those
companies, and especially
the companies in
fish, they will try
to use every single
part of the fish.
And it's the same as
like with the restaurant.
It's something that we focus
really, really hard on.
We want to get whole pieces
of whatever we are buying
and we want to use
every single part of it.
Or even if we are not
going to buy whole things,
we will buy some strange part
that nobody else is using.
As well, it's like
with everything--
like with vegetables,
for example--
it's like we try to use
if it comes with roots
and it comes with the
leaves, we will use it all.
And unfortunately, so many
farmers and people in general,
they don't know
what-- like, they
will get a celeriac
or something.
And they will get it
so they have already
cut the roots and
the leaves off,
which is a shame because it's
really, really good, as well.
So we try to talk
about those things
and get people to bring the
whole thing so we can just
use it.
We even have our
farmers bringing us
the wheat that grows
around the vegetables
because we will use
that for salad, as well.
Everything from like
the peel from the onions
we will put on a hot plate
in summer until it's dry,
and then we'll use
it to smoke with.
So we try to question
every single piece that
goes into the truss and
ask, what can I do with it?
JODY EDDY: I think this is
the blue mussel producer
that Gunnar works with.
And he has told
this story about how
when Gunnar started
placing his mussel orders,
they were the only
orders coming in.
And he would go out to
sea to collect sometimes
2 kilos for you and that was it.
And now he really is
having a hard time,
I think, keeping up with
business and the demand.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
I think it's going good.
JODY EDDY: But I
think it certainly
speaks to you just
really putting
that on the table at Dill and
allowing people to experience
it and then to want it
everywhere they go in Iceland.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
And for me it's really fun
to keep this good connection
to those guys and being able
to know what is behind it
and what they have been
doing or sacrificing
to bring those products to me.
JODY EDDY: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And this is our sea
bird egg collector.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
So this is out in Grimsey.
It's actually the
northest part of Iceland.
It's a three hour
trip on a ship.
JODY EDDY: It's an island
on the Arctic Circle.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
It's a very small island.
Yeah.
The Arctic Circle goes
through it, literally.
And my friend, Sigi, he actually
goes on a rope down those
cliffs to collect those eggs.
JODY EDDY: There's
some pictures of him.
It's really intense.
And they're not attached, too.
In contemporary climbing, you
attach yourself to the ground,
but his rope was wrapped
around a tractor hitch
that Gunnar was holding,
and that was it.
And we asked him if
there are ever accidents
and he said, yeah, all the time.
But he continues to do his work.
And it's inspiring, but
a little disconcerting
too, what he's doing
to collect those eggs.
But I think certainly,
again, it speaks
to the perseverance
and the determination
to keep tradition alive
amongst some people.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
And it's funny,
he would go and collect them
and then he just has a lot.
And the other people
from the island,
they will know that
he went yesterday
and then they'll come
and get a couple of eggs.
JODY EDDY: They have kind
of a collecting area, right?
A cooler.
There's 86 people on
the island, so it's
a small, tight-knit community.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: A
very, very small community.
JODY EDDY: The eggs
are shaped like cones
because the birds
don't build nests.
And so they just have
evolved into cones
so they don't roll off
the side of the cliff.
Very practical.
And we had some fantastic
hard boiled sea bird eggs
that night.
Sigi is also a
fisherman and so we
went out with him about 40
kilometers into the ocean
and fished.
And he, as well, talked
about the challenges
with the fishing quotas now.
The government can
be-- it's a struggle.
And he's actually gone north.
His family is not
from the island.
They used to fish in
the southern parts,
but because the fish are moving
further north because probably
from global warming, he's had to
move north to follow the fish.
But he's on the top
of the world now.
So you have to wonder what
he's going to do next.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: He's
not going any more north.
JODY EDDY: And this is some of
the goat sausage from the goat
farmer that we mentioned before.
And those are her
Icelandic goats.
There's Gunnar.
We spent a lot of time
with those goats one day.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
That was pretty neat.
JODY EDDY: There's Johanna.
And these are the lava fields on
the way to the hakarl producer.
He's the shark maker.
And there's his putrefied shark.
He eats his shark--
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
It tastes like cheese.
JODY EDDY: It supposedly tastes
like a really strong Stilton.
I don't know.
I've had it a few
times and I could never
discover that flavor.
He eats a shark sandwich
every day, this producer.
And he swears by it.
And he's 80 and his
skin is fantastic.
I think there's something
to the shark oil.
And he's so enthusiastic
about his work.
And there's the
shark fermenting.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
They actually
start with like fermenting
the sharks in those barrels
under like a pressure before
they actually then hang them up
to dry.
JODY EDDY: Here's some
pictures from our photo shoots.
It was really challenging
to shoot outside.
So we didn't do all
of our shoots inside.
With Icelandic weather--
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: So
if you're doing a book
and the photographer
says that he
wants to use the natural light
because it's so beautiful,
don't listen to him.
JODY EDDY: Just say no.
In a rainstorm all his mise en
place strewn across the stones.
It was a challenge.
And there's Gunnar's-- I love
this picture-- your daughter,
who is contemplating
one of your dishes.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
Checking it out.
JODY EDDY: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And for the book Gunnar's
friend, August, took us out
in his prop plane and we
did some aerial shots.
I was sitting in the back.
It was a little
nerve-racking every time
he would open up the
window and they would shoot
and then he would
tip to the side right
over the volcano
that had exploded
in 2011 or over
a glacier, but we
did what we had to
do to get the shot.
It was really fascinating
to see Iceland
after all these
years from the air
and see how it all fit together.
I have a picture here of coffee.
I think it really speaks
to where Iceland is at now
and how it's evolved
since the crisis.
This is a friend of Gunnar's
who runs this company.
And I think just the care that's
going into his product I think
speaks to a lot of the care and
diligence that a lot of people
have now to creating artisanal
beers and products that really
are of high quality and using
Icelandic-- coffee isn't
an Icelandic ingredient, but
in terms of just focusing on
of making it the best.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
Actually if you're
importing it, then you
should import something good.
JODY EDDY: Yeah.
Absolutely.
To talk a little bit about
the serviceware in the book,
everything was sourced
from Icelandic potters.
And we even had some of
the service wear brought
from the National Art Museum
that he was shooting on,
and then we had to run it
back to the museum that night
because they were not happy.
But even some of the pelts that
are used in the background,
we had a seal pelt and reindeer
hides and it's very inspiring.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON:
And it's all right now
everything at the restaurant.
So those pictures are actually--
JODY EDDY: Those are my
photos that I took at dinner.
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: They
are from our ex-location.
So we just moved
like four months ago.
And if I was moving
anyway, we decided
to take the whole
thing even further,
make it even more Icelandic.
So now everything
in the restaurant--
like the chairs, the
tables, every plate,
and all this stuff, everything
is handcrafted in Iceland.
We have some lamb
leather on the chairs.
And it's really, really, really
pretty and it's very Icelandic.
And I'm very happy.
JODY EDDY: Very
much you, I think.
GUNNAR KARL
GISLASON: Definitely.
JODY EDDY: So there's our
photographer and Gunnar
on the road.
Does anybody have any questions?
AUDIENCE: You've obviously
done a really great job
of telling the story
of the producers
and the origins of the
ingredients and everything.
Is that a responsibility
that more chefs should do?
Is it something that needs to
be done in more restaurants?
And if so, how best to
do it to a dining crowd
that's here to eat
their meal and then they
leave to do something else.
How do you balance
the story that you've
told in the book with the
guests in the restaurant?
GUNNAR KARL GISLASON: Yeah.
I definitely think that those
stories should be told more.
But, obviously, I
mean, I really don't
know how the situation
is somewhere else.
But I just felt
really like in Iceland
and especially at this time
that those stories should
come out and I really,
really just wanted
to embrace those things that
they were doing because I was
really, really impressed
with their stuff.
JODY EDDY: Thank you
for coming today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]